Gary what's been the one most rewarding
part of the Sherman's long release sure
there's many things but what stands out
to you the most
most rewarding I'd say just the
satisfaction of sitting in the room in
the screening in the theater with my
colleagues that the actor is true
watching it and seeing the response from
the audience and I know a lot of
filmmakers don't really like to watch
their films after they're done and I
don't necessarily sit back in my own
home watching my own phones but I love
sharing it with people I love seeing
them laugh and it's supposed to be funny
I love them you know being you know in
all when the score and the overt or
storage or when you know they hear all
the arrangements and the beautiful
performance and dancing and by the
actors so that's that shared experience
that there's no way I could have made
this film on my own like I needed to
have people to sing dance act write the
music there's nothing I just felt like
all I had to do is put these talented
people together and watch them play you
know and seeing them share that
experience and seeing them get other
work because of it is something that was
probably the most rewarding
what do you say to filmmakers or even
actors that can't watch their work I
mean for our interactive series we did
about 24 of them and I would say a third
of the filmmakers who could not do in
the audience you'd find them outside by
themselves a table right and and I get
that it is it is hard because would have
been a laugh at the one moment right to
intended what if they laugh at the
serious moment right so what do you say
to that is that just whatever process
works for them right i have a shot of
jameson you know that always huh i I /
on the I burn a hole in the car because
I do pace if I actually do watch in the
back of that happens I don't sit but if
I'm if I'm sitting it's something where
is for me it's a learning experience
it's not just sitting back in and just
you know sharing and just being happy
about it but a lot of time i'm actually
studying the people and i know a lot of
filmmakers do this they watch the
audience you guys more than the screen
because you know the film so well you're
just watching now how you know why does
this seem still feel long like i did
test screen it you know and so now i
feel it's in a good spot but sometimes
i'm watching it like you know you're
still learning about the pacing of us
stuff you're still learning about other
things and watching the people when
they're you know engaged you can tell
and you can tell in the summers you know
each audience is different but i can
tell certain areas that now based on
that kind of feedback i'm learning for
the next film how to kind of tweak and
play with the different kind of film
language lessons that I've learned from
this one into like
so maybe filmmakers and should take it
as a way to be sensitive even if it's
just not nothing is said but just sort
of the movement of the audience and they
can
what's working what's too long yeah I
definitely feel that it's but it's again
each filmmaker you know has a different
mindset in terms of are they making it
just for themselves they don't care what
the audience things or are they trying
to make it as commercial as they can so
it actually will play to the broadest of
audience it's like I think it everyone
has their own agenda and so just it's
mine that when I go in I always want to
improve myself like I want to be able
for the next film you know take what
I've learned of course and try to
improve upon what I felt were the kind
of the weaknesses of what had done
before and a lot of that is watching it
with other people to kind of feel their
response you know their innate immediate
response versus reading even review
because sometimes reviews are always you
know date later a week later after they
SAT and actually thought about the film
with when you're actually there with the
people you can really tell how to feel
about it
do you think is most filmmakers are as
intuitive as you are you seem very
intuitive do you think how do you think
that if it's not something that's
already in them that they should try to
acquire it if that's possible now I mean
it's again that's just me I think other
filmmakers I mean there's some genius
filmmakers out there that don't need to
do that because what they're their
instincts are so great that you know
whatever they put up there is probably
kick ass already but i'm i'm not you
know one where it's like I know I could
have done better and said just I feel
watching it with that audience will
pinpoint some of those those areas and
again it's also seeing where it works
very well like cool like that worked you
know and what did I remember when I did
that seem you know what kind of lessons
I remember like kind of like those ones
those lessons keep in your pocket cuz
you know those work you know
you